[Music]
what happens when the toaster gives up
the ghost and it's just past the end of
its guarantee
what if it could be fixed instead of
replaced
that's exactly what repair cafes like
this one in amsterdam are helping people
to do repair their broken consumer goods
slaves
the european parliament is calling for
new rules which would encourage
manufacturers to make everyday consumer
items more repairable
part of the right to repair is actually
also better information to consumers and
a repair score we have it already in
countries like france
would basically show in a very easy
manner if the product is easy to repair
or not proposals include ending
programmed obsolescence and promoting
products that last longer the european
parliament wants this to be done through
longer warranties and better
availability of spare parts it also
wants software updates to continue to
work on older devices we in the european
parliament we demand that also
software updates
are available much longer and are also
basically aligned with the expected
lifetime of a product
mep say such legislation is key to
developing a circular economy reaching
climate neutrality while saving money
energy and resources
for parliament it's time to put an end
to the throwaway society